alors maintenant johnny comme c'est la
première fois que je te reçois je vais
te faire une interview première fois
[Musique]
alors je lui ton premier non tout le
monde croit que c'est se met en fête
c'est clair comme julien c'est le nom de
ta mère parce que ton père était assez
volage il a attend mois chez claude moi
non
les stagiaires qui vont sillonner
temps père était quelqu'un d'assez m'a
tellement fait pour la bas tellement
fait pour la pour la vie de famille et
quelques jours après la naissance il a
vendu les meubles il affronte du même
nom et y est dix jours après la
naissance il grandit vite 1 1 et 8 mois
plus tard il a quitté le domicile
conjugal et donc ta mère s'est retrouvé
comme ça toute seule et elle a retrouvé
un an après elle a obligé à l'épouser
mais son vrai nom ton vrai premier non
c'est clair cette semaine c'était gai de
claire
jusqu'au mariage à l'essai jusqu'au
mariage de ma mère c'était clair qui
était mannequin chez fat est une très
jolie femme et qui vit toujours et qui
vit toujours mais doit être fier et
je crois que les fans bien réussi quand
même quoi qu'on en dise
c'est vrai que c'est un peu un voyou
mais bon être la maman de johnny doit
doit être fier je vais donner du troc à
un oui mais bon c'est faire bien du
souci alors ce père léon se mettent donc
johnny vous le reverrez vingt ans plus
tard vous vous avez 21 ans fait votre
service militaire en allemagne et un
jour il ya un mec qui vous dit fallait à
l'entrée de la caserne on vous y allez
c'est un ordre vous y allez et à ce
moment là vous voyez un type qui se
jettent sur vous en disant johnny johnny
monfils est en vous mettant un ours en
peluche dans dans les bras et c'était
votre père
et quelques années plus tard vous
apprendrez qu'en fait c'était un coup
qu'il avait monté avec les paradis
oui mais enfin bon ça s'est passé ouais
je préfère pas
trop parler de ce à quoi vous l'avez
vachement aider à préparer votre père
non oui enfin j'ai fait ce que j'ai pu
mais c'était pas toujours facile parce
que j'avais pris un appartement et puis
je reçois des coups de téléphone dans la
nuit comme quoi il avait mis le feu
ouais dans l'appartement il sait jamais
j'ai essayé beaucoup de choses puis à un
moment donné j'ai baissé les bras un
message pour dire que tu me pique mes
veines exc
non c'est vrai qu'en voulu acheter des
costumes ces routes il aller les
revendre quand quand vous lui louer un
appartement il mettait le feu
effectivement donc c'était assez assez
désespérant finalement dossier comme il
était alors même où la maman j'ai baissé
les bras mais j'ai laissé faire et ça
l'a vécu qu'il voulait savoir reggiani
vous à vous a parlé de lui une fois vous
un jour je rencontrais djallit qui me
dit tu sais je sais que tu as eue je
demeurais apprécions le temps permet moi
j'allais prendre des cours tous les tous
les week-ends à bruxelles chez lui
c'était un professeur d'art dramatique
est ordinaire ouais
et puis un jour vous allez l'enterrement
de ce père un petit peu inconnu d'une
certaine façon à un cheikh des camps en
belgique j'ai presque eu ma tristesse
qui va avoir d'abord étonné mais surtout
attristé c'est que j'étais tout seul il
n'y avait personne ouais c'est bien la
première faute était tout seul
mais c'était pas gai
dans cette histoire c'est un petit peu
déboussolé un d'une certaine façon c'est
tandis que vous avez eue après de créer
une famille est pas y arriver c'est
peut-être dû à sa finale devant le sans
faire de la psychanalyse à deux balles
c'est peut-être ça l'histoire non il
faut d'abord avant de créer une famille
il faut tomber sur la bonne personne
n'était jamais tombé sur la bonne
personne et cette fois-ci bon cette fois
ci je crois que suis bien trompé ouais
ça a l'air autour des sons
une fois avec son ordinaire qui je suis
très heureux elle était temps parce que
alors vous avez été élevé par votre
tante hélène marais votre première scène
c'est à 4 ans vous en souvenez de ça en
47 à londres non non dans une pièce ce
qui s'appelle caligula de camus fait le
rôle d'un petit 9-6 n'est pas du tout
premier souvenir vous souvenez c'est à
londres ben quoi c'est le doigt dans un
rail d'escalators ans honnête j'avais ma
première guitare
quel âge
vers avoir 12 ans ouais vous étiez à
rome avec vos cousins des stars elie et
vous avez à ce moment-là rencontré un
guitariste de flamenco oui il faisait
une tournée théâtrale au cloud y avait
comme ça des tas de numéro 2 de music
hall il y avait des gitans il y avait
des acrobates bon et il y avait dans la
troupe des gitans il y avait un
guitariste flamenco qui m'a appris à
jouer un peu plus tard
la jota
plein de choses oui et ça d'un droit non
plus et ensuite on a acheté une guitare
donc avec des coques ans classique a
permis le retour au flamenco le
bientôt bientôt
premier rôle au cinéma 1954 en souvenez
diabolique
vous aviez une petite annonce dans
france soir et comme il n'est pas de blé
à la maison votre temps de vous à les
emmener là bas j'avais passé un casting
avait pris way dans l'état dans la
classe d'enfants mais j'étais la
figuration ce n'est pas un robin et
j'avais deux phrases à dire qui a été
coupée donc ça ne veut pas très bon mais
on vous voit dans le film vous laver les
dents vous savez ça oui je
premier cachet de johnny hallyday en
1955 à un oeuvre premier cachet c'est un
coca cola vous aviez chanter davy
crockett sur scène me souviens de ses
chansons d'amy croquer david avec
raquettes à neige areva 1 j'ai chanté en
duo avec johnny
j'ai fait mon premier duo avec c'est
bien l'idée
mais vous êtes montés très très tôt sur
les planches enfin c'est ce qu'on sait
ce qu'on découvre mais c'est normal
parce que j'ai été élevé par une par une
famille d'artistes y est j'ai beaucoup
qui faisait beaucoup de music hall
beaucoup de cabaret donc
je voyais pas très honnêtement je ne me
voyais pas comptable plus tard juin
loyer plutôt artistes mais ça doit quand
même perturbé sa d'être sur scène
aussitôt non non c'est comme j'ai comme
j'en ai fait mon métier c'est plutôt une
chance pringy j'ai eu le temps
d'apprendre avant d'être connu
maintenant ce que je veux maintenant ce
que ce que je reproche un petit peu
c'est qu'on lance d'aider des gens on
essaie de leur apprendre à danser à
chanter en quatre mois jean les lens
comme des stars ils n'ont pas le temps
ils n'ont pas ils n'ont pas et ils n'ont
ils n'ont pas eu la commande irles la
formation la formation merci merci
beaucoup merci vaincu génie de
strasbourg pour
pour aller sur une scène d'être lancée
comme star il faut apprendre son métier
avant et on leur laisse pas le temps
d'apprendre alors effectivement quand on
les voit sur scène la première fois les
gens peuvent être peut-être déçu ce
n'est pas que le fait de choc de
chantier qui est important c'est le fait
de savoir aller et sortir d'une scène
savoir bouger sur une scène en fait un
forain quoi je le suis un oui en quelque
sorte oui c'est pas péjoratif
non non on va pas du tout j'adore les
femmes enceintes alors première bagarre
c'était avec la bande de la trinité non
j'imagine
et avait dutronc il y avait longue crise
il y avait dit mitchell tirez vous
preniez des dérouillées par les mecs de
la bande du sacré coeur où la bande de
la bastille ouais ils étaient plus
nombreux que les pieds combien vaut
alors ils étaient une vingtaine un essai
deux sens
c'était plié votre première petite amie
vous en souvenez
ma première petite taille moyenne
elle vous regarde elle est la première
petite amie c'est claude pécha bravo
jeune hina
en train puisque à l'époque vous n'aviez
pas encore de voiture à votre première
idole c'est brassens c'est fait vous
auriez voulu avoir brassens avec les
grosses vestes en velours il est qui est
rassurant
c'est rassurant
pas de brel aussi c'est une de vos
premières idoles et et vous dit s'il
avait fait du rock qui nous aurait tous
intérêt c'est vrai parce que il chante
avec sa poésie les il l'interpréter sur
scène avec l'énergie et le désespoir
d'un rockeur je ne connais pas d'autres
chanteurs que brel 1 qui transpirait
autant qu'il vomissait avant de rentrer
sur celles à long mais tous les records
ne produisent pas avoir un
titre inspiré qui zonaient qui seront
faire autant car à caracas bref vous
trouvez ça bien là qu'on réédite des
choses qu'ils voulaient pas voir éditer
écouter tout le monde évidemment curieux
longtemps que ça mais par rapport à sa
mémoire je trouve pas ça très bien alors
dit moi il ya des trucs à toi comme ça
qui ont été faits que que personne n'a
entendu
dire dans quelques real humer le feu ne
s'est jamais sentie
dans ta première qu'est ce tu t'en
souviens ouest entre on veut l'engin
bravo une terre 3 à 18 ans dès qu'il a
eu la première boîte
août est sorti
ou tu es rentré déjà way
première boîte je suis sorti alors là
ça c'est pas j'en ai fait beaucoup la
première l époque de la banque de la
trinité j'imagine non album jours ago
trop et c'est sa
première boîte comme propriétaire c'est
celle qui ouvre sa et 2003 voilà 2003 il
aura fallu attendre 2003 pour que johnny
hallyday et sa boîte à lui ouais mais ça
une histoire c'est de boîtes que j'ai
monté là on va en parler relève
en fait
cette voie que c'est une histoire de
coeur en fête absolument c'est j'ai
rencontré
j'ai rencontré laëtitia il ya neuf ans à
miami ouais et
c'est drôle d'ailleurs parce qu'à
l'époque jean roch travailler pour andré
boudou le père de laeticia le père du
tysabri et il me téléphone je devais
partir je disais que je te fais fort je
dis rien je que l'epa miami mme du si tu
veux on dit dans sa revue d'accord ils
arrivent en voiture avec andré boudou
laetitia est là la femme d'andré on va
dîner après on va on va à l'amnesia de
gianni de miami et puis la soirée se
passe on va dans votre boîte est bon on
rentre tard et le lendemain je revois
laetitia et puis je rentre sur paris et
donc je rentre sur paris on a continué à
ce que les faunes et caetera et puis un
mois après laetitia série télé via paris
elle devait rester une semaine et puis
il n'est jamais reparti mais elle n'a
jamais servi le
btp rembourser j'ai voulu faire j'ai
voulu faire par rapport à par rapport à
l'endroit où je vais le rencontrer je
voulais faire la boîte de nuit à paris
les corrections de nourrir hydrater de
1h10 tube abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux